[Música]
bienvenidos a áfrica 710 un magazine
informativo dedicado a áfrica comenzamos
con los titulares el rey felipe de
bélgica visita la república democrática
del congo a partir del 7 de junio
durante seis días
este viaje histórico podría ser la
oportunidad para que la antigua potencia
haga frente a su doloroso legado
colonial
seguimos en la república democrática del
congo y hablamos de las crecientes
tensiones entre este país y ruanda
mientras se reanudaron los
enfrentamientos entre el m23 y el
ejército del congo las autoridades
congoleñas acusan a kigali de apoyar la
rebelión
tenemos análisis el mandatario senegalés
mcchystal quien ostenta la presidencia
rotatoria de la unión africana se
declaró satisfecho por su encuentro con
vladimir putin macky sall viajó a rusia
para defender los intereses del
continente africano amenazado por una
crisis alimentaria sin precedentes como
consecuencia de la guerra en ucrania
se trata sin duda de un punto de
inflexión en las relaciones entre
kinshasa y bruselas por primera vez
desde el inicio de su reinado en 2013 el
rey felipe de bélgica viaja a la
república democrática del congo
el monarca recorrerá la ex colonia belga
del 7 al 13 de junio bélgica en el congo
evoca sobre todo la tiranía del rey
leopoldo 2 sobre el país cuando las
potencias europeas se repartieron áfrica
en la conferencia de berlín en
1885 bélgica se quedó con el congo donde
leopoldo segundo instauró un brutal
sistema de explotación los campos de
caucho eran escenario de la violencia
sin límites
impuesta por este rey contra la
población congoleña los trabajadores que
no cumplían con las exigencias
productivas de los terratenientes eran
sometidos a castigos corporales como la
flagelación la amputación de miembros o
incluso la muerte
sin distinción entre de trato entre
niños y adultos más de un siglo después
de la muerte del rey el racismo la
violencia y otras formas de
discriminación
siguen siendo un tabú en bélgica donde
la figura de leopoldo 2 nunca ha sido
oficialmente cuestionada sin embargo en
2020 el rey felipe expresó por primera
vez su arrepentimiento por las heridas
que bélgica causó en el pasado a raíz de
estos comentarios una comisión
parlamentaria fue encargada es de
esclarecer el pasado colonial de bélgica
en el congo ruanda y burundi seguimos en
la república democrática del congo donde
el 19 de mayo el movimiento del m23 y
los militares congoleños volvieron a
enfrentarse desde entonces las tensiones
entre kinshasa y kigali han aumentado la
república democrática del congo acusa a
wanda de apoyar a la rebelión mientras
que por otro lado incluso la población
congoleña se está movilizando para
apoyar al ejército
para entender lo que está en juego
hablamos con david soler periodista y
editor de áfrica mundi le preguntamos
qué es el m23 y cuáles son sus objetivos
el 23 es un grupo rebelde armado del
este de república democrática como la
provincia del club que llevaba inactivo
de ese tema de 9 años surgió después de
la segunda guerra del congo un poder que
se había integrado en ejércitos no
estaba contento con sus condiciones y
básicamente se extinguió él creó un
grupo rebelde que llegó a tener mucha
importancia e incluso capturó la ciudad
de goma la más importante de gracias el
equipo sus demandas entonces eran
básicamente más para ver las condiciones
de la región
incluso en su momento de mayor fuerza
cuando llegaron a contar con miles de
hombres pedían la cabeza del entonces
presidente joseph kabila y desde
entonces eso sí se retiraron de la
actividad de goma y no habían tenido
ninguna actividad en casinos
la república democrática del congo
afirma que uruguay apoya a este grupo
uruguaya niega estas acusaciones y a su
vez acusa a la república democrática del
congo de apoyar a milicias formadas por
tus tras el genocidio tutsi de
1994 la rdc ya ha suspendido los vuelos
de la compañía ruandesa rumbo under en
su territorio y ha retirado a su
embajador le preguntamos a the beat'
soler hasta dónde puede escalar el
conflicto actual es difícil prever si
esto va a ser una nueva escalada de
tensión desde hace ya muchos años de
república democrática como no tienen
buenas relaciones con ruanda sí que es
verdad que la salida de kábila la
llegada es estéril o había mejorado
incluso la llegada hace poco a la
comunidad de áfrica oriental de
república democrática del congo parecía
que iba a mejorar las cosas pero siguen
en sus trece desde
1996 cuando allí se
escondieron el día es q tu idioma las
relaciones por culpar ruanda en este
caso república democrática del congo de
protegerles y al revés república
democrática del congo ruanda ni madres
en territorio y expoliar sus recursos es
difícil prever que vaya mucho más son
países vecinos con muchos intereses
comunes y no se puede traer una guerra a
escala de la región pero sí que ocurra y
por detectores y se hará en el tiempo
este tipo de financiación a los
deprimentes locales por uno y otro bando
para luchar entre ellos sin una
participación activa de los ejércitos de
ambos países uno en contra los maquis al
el presidente senegalés que ostenta la
presidencia de la unión africana visitó
rusia el viernes 3 de junio para hablar
con vladimir putin de las repercusiones
de la guerra de ucrania en el continente
africano macky sall dijo estar
satisfecho de su encuentro a pesar de
que el presidente ruso esquivar a
mencionar en sus declaraciones públicas
las consecuencias de la guerra sobre la
inseguridad alimentaria de áfrica
putin prefirió dirigir sus palabras a
alabar la lucha de los africanos contra
el colonialismo escuchemos a nuestro
país rusia siempre ha estado del lado de
áfrica y siempre lo ha apoyado en su
lucha contra el colonialismo
colonialismo
creemos que con las distintas naciones
africanas en general hemos tenido
tradicionalmente muy buenas relaciones
yo diría que amistosas sin exagerar
áfrica en su conjunto tiene un enorme
potencial y sobre esa base seguiremos
desarrollando nuestras relaciones con
las distintas naciones del continente
consanguíneos el presidente senegalés
también señaló a occidente las
consecuencias de las sanciones a rusia
sobre el sistema alimentario global
mientras que muchos países del
continente dependen en más de un 50% de
las importaciones de trigo de ucrania y
rusia los precios de este cereal han
subido alrededor de un 45 por ciento
desde el inicio de la guerra según
cifras del banco africano de desarrollo
para mitigar los efectos de esta crisis
la unión africana ha pedido a europa que
revise sus sanciones contra el kremlin
como la exclusión de algunos bancos
rusos del sistema financiero swift esta
medida en particular afecta al
suministro de aume de alimentos de todo
el continente
el miércoles hablé con el consejo
europeo y les dije que sí que está a la
guerra que está la crisis pero que
también están las sanciones
de salsa y que debemos trabajar juntos
para resolver ambos problemas debemos
asegurarnos de que todo lo relacionado
con suministro de alimentos y cereales
no se vea afectado por las sanciones
andrew cuomo orgulloso vamos a nigeria
donde un grupo de hombres armados atacó
una iglesia el domingo 5 de junio en el
suroeste del país y mató al menos a 50
personas según un informe publicado el
lunes 6 de junio por las autoridades
locales el ataque que no ha sido
reivindicado se produjo durante la misa
de pentecostés en una iglesia católica
de la localidad de huguá en el estado en
el estado de hondo la seguridad sigue
siendo un reto importante en el país más
poblado de áfrica que es también la
mayor economía del continente los
ataques a sitios religiosos son
especialmente delicados ya que aumentan
las tensiones entre las como es el sur
de nigeria es de mayoría cristiana y el
norte de mayoría musulmana sin embargo
este tipo de ataques es relativamente
poco frecuente en el suroeste del país
pero en el resto del territorio el
ejército nigeriano se enfrenta a
numerosos focos de inseguridad
hace tres meses abandonaron ucrania
después de que la invasión rusa
interrumpiera sus estudios en el país
70.000 estudiantes extranjeros dejaron
todo para huir de los combates 3000 han
encontrado refugio en alemania la gran
mayoría de ellos son estudiantes
africanos pero a diferencia de los
refugiados ucranianos que tuvieron un
acceso inmediato a la ayuda del estado
alemán y a un permiso de residencia las
autoridades alemanas así como otros
gobiernos europeos dejaron atrás a los
refugiados de terceros países
un informe de and may
todos los domingos se reúnen en este
jardín comunitario de berlín son
refugiados de la guerra de ucrania pero
proceden de terceros países como mohamed
a este joven keniano huyó de quiebra el
24 de febrero pero a diferencia de los
ciudadanos ucranianos en europa no tiene
acceso a la protección temporal que
concede un derecho de residencia
inmediato a los exiliados
es muy difícil para los estudiantes
extranjeros antes disfrutábamos de una
serie de privilegios en ucrania y
hacíamos cosas buenas como estudiar y
ahora es muy difícil establecerse en
otro país europeo 70.000 estudiantes
extranjeros estudiaban en ucrania antes
de la guerra al parecer hasta 3000 de
ellos encontraron refugio en alemania
pero no tienen acceso a la vivienda al
mercado laboral ni a las prestaciones
sociales en berlín cuentan con el apoyo
de varias organizaciones que reclaman
los mismos derechos para todos los
refugiados
es tan injusto no puede haber refugiados
de primera y segunda clase
con explicar el problema está
relacionado con la discriminación
estructural y el racismo son personas
que han habido exactamente lo mismo que
los ucranianos ellos también lo han
perdido todo pero aquí nos fijamos sobre
todo en el lugar de donde presionan
antes una situación administrativa
precaria sin perspectivas de futuro con
la amenaza de deportación a su país de
origen para estos jóvenes estudiantes la
incertidumbre es difícil encontrar
estamos completamente integrados en la
comunidad europea llevamos tanto tiempo
viviendo aquí que no tenemos nada que no
vinculen a nuestro país de origen
siento que me voy a derrumbar y no sabía
el único en esta situación esto le
ocurre a toda la gente con este nuevo
color por el momento estos estudiantes
originarios en su mayoría de áfrica y
oriente medio sólo tienen un permiso de
residencia temporal hasta el 31 de
agosto pero todos esperan obtener pronto
un visado de estudiante
el 15 de marzo el mundo descubrió el
ganador del premio pritzker 2022 de
arquitectura su nombre es diébédo
francis quiere oriundo de burkina faso
es el primer africano en obtener esta
distinción su trayectoria consiste en
una carrera rica en obras de compromiso
con la justicia social con
construcciones sostenibles y adaptadas
al entorno natural
tras los homenajes en todo el mundo y la
entrega del premio el 27 de mayo en
londres
francis kéré regresó a su país para una
estancia de una semana
[Música]
les dejamos con las imágenes de su
regreso triunfal gracias por
acompañarnos y más información en france
24 y france 24 puntocom
[Música]